let's say that you're throwing a party
and as we all know any party needs a
sufficient number of monkeys right now
you have 10 monkeys 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
but you would like to have 18 monkeys so
how many more monkeys do you need in
order to have 18 monkeys and i encourage
you to pause the video and think about
it on your own before i work through it
so remember the goal here
was is to get to
the goal here let me write this way the
goal here is to get to
18
18 monkeys
now what do we know about the number 18.
well the number 18 you have this one
right over here in the tens place
so that literally represents 1
10
and then this 8 represents 8 ones
so plus
eight
ones
and that's the same thing as saying one
ten
one ten that's just a ten right over
there and eight ones that's just eight
so eighteen is the same thing as 10 plus
8.
so if we start with 10 monkeys which is
how many we have started with how many
more do we need to get to 18
well if you start at 10 you need 8 more
to get to 18. and we can verify that
visually if we like so let's
so let's
see
let me copy and paste one of these
monkeys
copy
so this is 10 so now let's get to 18.
so 11
and 18.
so how many more did we add well once
again we started
we started with this 10 right over here
let me box them off
we started
with these 10 monkeys
so that's one group of 10 right over
there so we started with
the ten
and then we added eight more monkeys one
two three four five six seven eight
one two three four five six seven eight
so we started with ten we added eight
more monkeys we added eight more monkeys
to get
to get to
a
teen and once again how did we first
think about that well eighteen is one
ten
plus eight ones or ten plus eight